ein euro 5 euro 10 euro hatten wir schon
heute essen wir einen tag für 20 euro
und ich bin sehr gespannt was mir da so
können kann ich glaube heute geht es
schon richtig richtig gut ich habe schon
eine idee wie zum frühstück hingehen
würde sagen vergeben wir sind sehr sehr
lecker und damit starten wir auch hier
an den wunderschönen lindenthaler kanäle
es ist wirklich sondern hat schon das
gefühl man gönnt sich heute richtig was
20 euro sind kein riesenbudget also wir
werden jetzt heute abend im sterne
restaurant sitzen aber ich habe heute
den großen luxus dass ich mir nicht
einen gesamten tagesplan machen muss
weil bisher war das irgendwo schon ein
stück weit möglich das einkaufen muss
den fokus wie klappt das ganze jetzt
kann ich außer haus wäre das holen was
mache ich jetzt auf und zwar gehen wir
zur kaffeetafel italienischen
generalkonsulat dort wohl ich mir ein
cappuccino vielleicht nach china oder
ein paar los geht's wir genießen den tag
[Musik]
bei cappuccino ein mandelgebäck und eine
art china für fünf euro 50 stück zum
frühstück wie für könige und es wirklich
dass es durch wirst du weniger ist
worauf ich jetzt mehr lust habe als auch
das und für fünf euro 50 etabliert
schauen wir uns doch unsere ausbeute an
ko ich sage so viel das wiegt schwer in
meiner hand das tablett das sind
eingebaute waagen 175 gramm locker 200
gramm das ist einfach nur so und so war
ich mir gönnen wollte und ist
funktioniert das so ganz ist fünf euro
50 jahre darauf wie sie italienische
donuts mit so einem durchmesser und für
1 euro 60 also fast genauso teuer wie
gast 150 rettungskräfte könnt ihr
einfach aus und wird gern aber was hier
stand so rauskommt oder käse die staaten
mit herzhaften der franzose
[Musik]
das ist ganz kurz für alle die nicht ist
und was ist dass seine garantie dass
also ein quasi zitiertes risotto welche
nur das jedoch wirklich so richtig dick
spina käse einfach nur leckere dinge
drin sind und es schmeckt wuchsen wieder
authentisch weil ich meine italienischen
konsulat gezielt leute die wissen was
gut ist das ist so lecker das kann man
wirklich so was von gut essen geladen
also diese kleine schöne absolutes
herzstück finde ich hier so von lisa von
dieser ecke und absoluter geheimtipp
davon werde ich so ganzen tag sein ich
muss er fünf euro 50 budget change
fertig bisher haben wir wirklich
ausnahmslos nur wasser trinken können
sich jetzt einen kaffee zu kaufen ist
wirklich schon ein maximaler luxus und
wir konnten bisher ein einziges mal was
beim bäcker holen jetzt ganz entspannt
also immer wirklich ganz entspannt so
muss ein höchst nicht wahr auch gucken
und meine das sind ja auch schon 600
euro im monat wenn man das auf jeden tag
rechnet wir werden sehen wie der rest
des tages verläuft aber ich hätte vom
kopf her gedacht ist das noch nicht
super einfach und komplette gerne ist
dann gespannt also das frühstück begann
und dieses gesamtpaket dass man hier an
den lindenthaler kanäle ist dass man
diese wunderschöne rote ab hat die
irgendwie so authentisches essen aus dem
anderen und wir sind hier das fühlt sich
echt alles schon so ein bisschen nutzen
also das möglich was für die ganze
erfahrung hier ist mir auch mehr wert
als viele male die ich schon irgendwie
ein zwar nie in einem frühstück
wächterrat geglaubt habe wo man dann
irgendwelche übertriebenen pancakes mit
was weiß ich was ist also das hier ist
wirklich 13 prozent
also es ist so ein mann der gedeckt mit
schokoladen füllungen einfach mitgenutzt
noch ein bisschen cappuccino strategisch
übrig gelassen
ich wäre schon fast so lang marzipan
also dieses typische zitronat orangeat
was so in diesem italienischen gepäck
des jubels greifen des sports sind so
fucking neidig gerade darf nicht also ja
er hätte außerhalb des budgets natürlich
auch was er macht alle diäten
damit kann ja nicht jeder sohn adonis
körper haben werden wir auch darüber
gesprochen ob das jetzt der erste dreier
nach zwei wochen gehe ich im urlaub
macht und es ist wirklich einfach
einsetzen diesen job machen zu dürfen
deshalb danke dafür zuschaut genießt das
jetzt zu ende angeblich zum nächsten
spox mit
[Musik]
okay das ist die ausbeute 1 150 ein
schwarm a93 das heißt fünf euro 40 von
unserem budget noch mal weg somit
bleiben uns im neuen eur 10 fürs
abendessen und der eindruck fest ich das
überhaupt kein problem guide zu essen
mit dem 2 schauen wir mal wie es
schmeckt ich finde es echt interessant
bei mir jetzt noch mal bewusst wird so
entweder man den fans wie pasta essen
und trinken cola dazu und gibt 20 euro
aus oder man gönnt sich einen tag lang
wirklich trotzdem geiles essen heute
abend wenn wir jetzt auch eine pasta
kochen aber wir haben immer noch neun
euro 10 auszugeben fürs abendessen bin
gespannt hörten hunger weil das auch
schon ordentliche apparat hirschi sicher
war es sowieso sehr gerne
dass die art liebe so diese zitrusnoten
die das hat gesehen dass die granatapfel
so dass er auch zieht ostermann leichte
schärfe sondern direkt ab mittag an
motiven ich weiß gar nicht was ich dazu
sagen soll ich meine das fleisch saftig
das gladiatoren frisches gemüse aber das
gefühl dass es wirklich so ist wenn man
mit nicht nur irgendwas reinhardt und
wie es bei ein euro war sondern man ist
auch so sinnvolle seien günstig so
geiles es ja das stimmt also ist nicht
um satt zu werden auch alles freut man
sich spätestens mit dem nächsten step
wenn wir dann 50 euro machen habe ich
schon alles an freiheiten was wir uns
wünschen können und eine weitere
freiheitlich dadurch habe dass ich jetzt
nicht nur noch 50 cent sondern neun euro
sehen übrig habe ist dass mal was kochen
kann brot lust habe ich habe heute am
fluss aufnehmen passt und die hab ich
und ihr vielleicht auch auf trikot
gesehen die war im ganzen internet es
hat sich in den reden gegangen nicht
mehr der discounter eingekauft uns nach
herzenslust einfach alles gepackt was
wir wollten dachten wir zumindest das
wurde dann doch ein bisschen enger als
vielleicht vermutet hätten zitronen
butter cappellini chiliflocken und ein
getränk genommen und sind bei 9 eur 10
auf den cent genau unserem restbetrags
bekommen deshalb 20 euro budget change
will ich sagen maximal ausgereizt und
hier haben wir alle das herz begehrt
wunderschöne zutaten trotzdem nicht so
viele aber kamen block mutter und vier
zitronen habe es ist eigentlich eine
familie portion weshalb haben ja gesagt
dass und runter daraus sind wenn man
jetzt immer außer dafür bekommen wenn du
immer schon viel geld
warum
wir haben aber auch vergessene vergessen
werden aber auch kein geld gehabt
deshalb interaktive gegen alle fälle
ok fangen wir alle lieben dich zu
treiben
festes ab jetzt brauchen wir den saft
und der duft der ist auf zack hätte ich
nicht schöner sagen können aber sagt ich
alles einen sinn ergeben
[Musik]
wir machen das ganze strikt nach rezept
sind erst mal ein wenig unser nicht
nudelwasser also das wird einfach nur
top mit warmen wasser dann nehmen wir
uns
mit unserem oder blogs mit denen unsere
fahne muss nur weil sie sommerlich ist
es noch keine lotterie kaster da wird
jetzt eigentlich der klose reinkommen
eingehackt nein so ist ruhe und der wird
am ende raus wurde weiß ich doch wir
machen ohne wird sein in die trierer
jetzt gehen wir rein das ist schon nicht
erst hat die nicht voll komisch
diszipliniert einfach
mitreißen und freunden heizöl
programmieren zu senken dass von unseren
salzwasser und geben dass kinder gut an
und wir dadurch kippte und ganz
natürlich waren es was daran geben haben
wir unsere chiliflocken
geben wir auch dazu kann ich verstehe
dass polen ist es ja auch was klassisch
italienische pasta in der pfanne zu
kochen langsam kommen wir so ein
bisschen im feld nicht lecker
aber man merkt haben auf jeden fall war
ganz interessant also die mühle einfach
an der ecke große findet schon auf jeden
tag ganz gut so an die nudeln und zucker
jetzt geben wir scheinbar unsere
zitronen sagte mayrhuber
jetzt liegt so interessant ich gehe aber
noch ein bisschen mehr butter dazu bei
einem großteil für die botschaft ist
schon so eine spaßige angelegenheit
kommen genau das meine ja das schon cool
also kann man dieses feature x naja ein
bisschen wasser liegt
das sind los so macht man pasta
basta
sparkling eistee zero gehen wir einmal
ein in die cappellini
klingen gut sehen und scheinbar auch
texte die so die ist man so am meer und
das sind befinden
[Musik]
spaß beiseite ich
meine ohne witz ich war gerade kurz
höchste bisher in lost vorwärts weil das
neue welt passt da kann säure basiert
sind sehr cremig wirklich willst wird
sehr sehr cremig schöne zitronen note
wunderbar frisch leichte chili geschmack
schärfe das ist so als wäre so ein
mantel aus öl so um jede einzelne nudel
gelegt der business perfekt und ich mag
es mehr als ich wollte weil ich dachte
ich ich würde so gerne mögen weil
irgendwie dachte ich das ist eine art
von pasta die mir nicht gefällt so weil
diese und sie ist schon älter ich kenne
den fall nicht aber ich vermisse auch
kein knoblauch der cappellini sind die
besseren spaghetti fast track trace ist
mario prämien die nehmen die soße
perfekt auch und die kann man sogar in
essen und die sind so umgehen so eine
masse das viel zu lecker 20 euro budget
challenge so leid es mir tut die lecker
surfen also sie haben schon leckere
sachen gehabt aber heute war von a bis z
einfach nur hochgenuss und frage mich
wirklich ob es unbedingt besser wird
wenn wir mehr geld ausgeben das wohl
einschalten bisschen voraus zu finden
dank fürs zu sehen die das mir schmecken
das gern leichter bis zum nächsten mal